In today's video,
we are seeing what happens
when molten metal meets crayons.
[Music]
Guys, before we begin,
I really want to address
the elephant in the room.
What are we melting?
Crayons.
Are you sure
they're not crayons?
I pronounce them crayons.
It's a two syllable word
starts with cray,
and ends with on.
What elementary
student says crayon?
It's crayon.
It's a crayon.
We're melting crayons.
Cray--
It's got--
It's got too many letters
to be one syllable.
It's crayon.
Crayon.
Cray-on.
A few moments later.
Either way.,we're going
to do some fun things
with molten metal.
Wax melts at
a very low temperature.
Aluminum melts at a much
higher temperature,
and we just want to see
what happens when they combine.
One interesting question is
whether or not the color
from the crayons can actually do
something to alter
the color of the metal.
What do you think?
You know, I'm gonna go with no.
You can't actually color metal.
In fact,
if you see colored metal,
it's plated, I believe.
Or painted or anodized.
I don't think
that there's a way to actually
add color to metal,
but crayons do have a lot
of color in them.
So maybe something will rub off?
Crayons themselves are made
of paraffin wax and pigment.
Now, paraffin wax,
believe it or not,
has a flash point.
It actually can be set on fire.
So, do you think that these
are actually going to melt,
or they just
gonna light on fire?
I bet both.
I think it's going to melt,
followed very quickly
by lighting on fire.
Both?
Both.
Both is good.
Here's the basic idea.
We're going to melt down
a bunch of aluminum,
and then add some crayons.
What's going to happen?
Will it melt the crayons?
Will it light them on fire?
Will the crayons actually
stain the color of the metal?
All right, Nate we
have got our foundry.
We have got...
Many crayons.
Many.
We got many crayons.
Let's melt some aluminum.
I like it.
[Music]
So the aluminum
that we're melting
isn't actually our normal wire
that we have.
Nate, what did you put in there?
It's half a roll
of aluminum foil.
It's aluminum foil.
It's a big heavy roll
of aluminum foil.
It's actually a pretty
easy source of aluminum to get.
This is, I'm sure, some alloy.
I don't imagine
this is perfectly
pure elemental aluminum,
but it's very close.
And so, we're going to use it.
It's cheap, it's easy,
and you can get
at the grocery store.
Crayons are made almost entirely
of wax with a little bit
of pigment inside,
and then of course,
paper wrapped around them.
What we're testing out is
the viability of using crayons
as candles in perhaps
an emergency situation.
I'm also curious to see
if the different colors burn
at different rates,
different speeds.
It already looks
like our black wax candle / crayon
is burning a little bit more
intensely than the others,
but we're going to see
how long they last as well.
I saw one supposed life hack
online that talked about
how a crayon will burn for,
and then it had
a specific amount of time.
But it said it
as though it was always going to
be exactly that amount of time,
so I'm curious
if different candles burn
for different rates.
What we'll see how they all do.
Maybe it's true.
Maybe it's not.
The idea is that the paper
is going to act as sort of
a wick for the molten wax,
kind of like
an inside-out candle.
The wick is on the outside
rather than on the inside.
Are they all going
to keep going?
We're going to have
to test and find out.
We already had two kind of fail,
and I'm not sure
exactly what happened.
I was able to relight them,
but the green and the yellow,
which are the ones
that went out, are now,
they're going out again.
[Music]
We're going to drop one crayon
into our molten aluminum.
See what happens.
Beautiful.
It's on fire.
Wow!
I think immediately,
the paper probably lit on fire.
So that is paraffin wax.
So do you think
the wax itself melted,
and is now just sitting
on the surface?
Because it's not as dense
as the aluminum.
That's true.
But it does catch fire.
We can--
We can sort of see
part of it now.
I think that's paper.
I think so.
I think the paper survived
for the most part.
Yes!
Melting, and on fire.
You can see the little
puddle of wax.
Your lighting your
camera on fire..
Oh, that's really cool.
And now, you can just
see it started dancing
on the surface of the aluminum.
That's exactly what I said.
I didn't think it was actually
gonna sink in.
>> You are right.
>> I thought it would melt on the top,
and light on fire.
With normal candles,
the heat from the wick
is actually vaporizing
a little bit of the wax,
>> and then it's that vapor.
>> The wax is the fuel.
Yeah.
It's that vapor
that actually ignites.
The liquid wax and the solid
wax aren't burning,
but the vaporized
wax is burning,
and so it's just
what you were pointing out is
that the stick,
when I pull it out,
it might get melty,
but it's not lighting on fire,
and that's why.
It's because it has to actually
vaporize to catch on fire.
[Music]
While we're waiting for that
to cool and not be on fire.
Yeah, it's still on fire.
Yep.
What should we do?
I think it's time to scale
it up a little bit.
We've done single crayons.
I want to see a lot of crayons
and more aluminum.
Okay, we've got a bowl
full of crayons and a crucible
full of molten metal.
Let's combine them.
I do not want to
be standing there.
Nothing.
That took me nothing.
It is actually staying on top.
I am amazed that
that has not just foam right to--
The fact that there's
aluminum on top
>> of the crayons is baffling.
>> Okay, but wait, listen.
Can you hear that?
It's boiling.
Oh, yeah.
[Music]
I fill this cup with crayons
with the papers on.
[Music]
Even though the paraffin
does catch fire,
it seems that our crayons
with the paper are definitely
staying lit a lot longer.
Wow.
Wow, that's...
That's an impressive
amount of flame,
and it is putting
off a lot of heat.
[Music]
You can still see the aluminum.
It didn't melt all
of the crayons all
the way through,
and that is amazing.
Yeah, the fact
that there's aluminum
draped across crayons,
I never would have thought
that they would hold--
>> No.
>> Hold aluminum.
I thought of just cut
right through them all.
Yeah, not in any shape or form.
That's awesome.
That's how I take it.
Really hot.
Yeah.
That is cool.
That was neat.
That is pretty...
Wait. What is that?
>> That's the aluminum.
>> That's the aluminum?
Awesome.
That's the crayon
wax right there.
[Music]
That is a funny
shape right there.
Look at that.
That is well coated with wax.
[Music]
There it is.
That is a chunk of aluminum
poured into a pile of crayons,
a bowl of crayons.
Crayons.
And then it's become coated
in crayon wax as well.
It's just covering it all.
So we'd have to try and burn all
that off to see the aluminum
underneath, I think.
[Music]
It's actually really
really pretty.
And warm.
Oh, it really is.
Also, it smells terrible.
It does.
None of the others
ever smelled this bad.
What are they called?
Crayons.
They have been,
and they always
shall be crayons.
No kindergartener says crayon.
I say February.
He's the weird one.
So right here,
where we've got this cool
little fire twirl,
this does kind of look
like the aluminum
and the crayons have
like blended together.
>> Maybe it's just a puddle
>> Yeah, that's so pretty.
of wax on top of aluminum,
but like right at the edges,
it almost looks
like we have wax mixing
with the metal.
Pouring metal onto crayons
looks super cool.
Guys, you know we've always
got more for you to see.
That box at the top
is going to take you right
into our last video.
You should go check that out.
The other box shows you
what YouTube thinks you
should be watching next.
And if you hit
this bomb the middle,
you'll get subscribe
to the channel.
So you don't miss any
of our cool videos.
Don't forget to ring the bell,
and we'll see you
in the next one.
Talk to you then.